A word of your listening with small children, this episode is about sex and sexuality. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the summer of 2017, Kate Devlin flew from London to Southern California, rented a Mustang convertible, and drove to an industrial park in San Marcos, a city south of Los Angeles. Her destination, Abyss Creations, a company that makes life-size, sex dolls.
提醒各位听众，如果有小孩子在旁请注意，本期节目讨论的是性与性意识。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。2017年夏天，凯特·德夫林从伦敦飞往南加州，租了一辆野马敞篷车，开往洛杉矶以南圣马科斯的一个工业园区。她的目的地是深渊创意公司，一家制造与真人大小相同的性爱娃娃的公司。
In her new book, Turned On, Science, Sex, and Robots, Kate describes the moment she first gazed up close at a life-size, silicone woman. The detail is incredible. My hand skims the ankle. The toes are perfect, little wrinkles on the joints, tiny ridges on the toenails. The sole is crisscrossed with the fine skin lines of a human foot.
在她的新书《被唤醒：科学、性与机器人》中，凯特描述了她第一次近距离端详一个真人大小的硅胶女性时的情景。细节太不可思议了。我的手掠过脚踝。脚趾完美无瑕，关节上有小小的褶皱，脚趾甲上有细小的纹路。脚底交织着人类足部细腻的皮肤纹理。
It's beautiful. Today we explore the long history of the artificial lover. From stone statues to silicone works of art, we have long sought solace and sex from inanimate objects. As the gap between humans and machines narrows, the possibility of deeper relationships seems ever more plausible, especially if those machines are beautifully designed to look like human beings and have the faint glow of empathy and intelligence. I like the way you take care of me.
太美了。今天我们探讨人造恋人的悠久历史。从石雕到硅胶艺术品，长期以来，我们一直试图从无生命的物体中寻求慰藉和性。随着人类与机器之间的鸿沟缩小，建立更深层次关系的可能显得越来越貌似合理，特别是如果这些机器在设计上完美得像人类，并散发出同理心和智能的微光的话。我喜欢你照顾我的方式。
She could do anything from telling you a joke, singing a song for you, or, you know, propositioning you. Hi, baby. What are you doing right now? Love and sex. Hi, baby. Hi, baby. In the age of robots.
她可以做任何事，从给你讲笑话、为你唱歌，或者，你知道的，向你求爱。嗨，宝贝。你现在在做什么？爱与性。嗨，宝贝。嗨，宝贝。在机器人的时代。
My main objective is to be a perfect companion. This week on Hidden Brain. Thinking about computers as companions is Kate Devlin's day job. She studies human computer interactions and artificial intelligence at King's College London. Kate, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you very much for having me on. I want to start with how someone becomes a robot sexologist. I understand for you it began with hanging out in a pub with a bunch of philosophers. It really did, yes, I was at a conference.
我的主要目标是成为一个完美的伴侣。本周在《隐藏的大脑》。把计算机当作伴侣是凯特·德夫林的日常工作。她在伦敦国王学院研究人机交互和人工智能。凯特，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我来。我想从一个人是如何成为一名机器人性学家开始。据我了解，对你来说，这一切始于和一群哲学家在酒吧里闲逛。确实如此，是的，当时我在参加一个会议。
A conference on cognitive systems and we were discussing lots of different attributes that we could build into robots on cognitive systems and AI. Should we, for example, get a make a robot that could feel pain. What about a robot that could feel empathy? And as we discuss more and more, and as the drink flowed, we began talking about sex, and it's something so fundamentally human. But what happens if we have machines, cognitive systems that could feel desire, that could feel the things we feel? As you point out in the book, the human fascination with artificial lovers is not a new idea. Where do you think this fantasy of taking a lover that isn't human? Where do you think it comes from?
一个关于认知系统的会议，我们当时在讨论许多不同的属性，我们可以将这些属性构建到认知系统和AI的机器人中。比如，我们是否应该制造一个能感觉到痛的机器人？那能感受到同理心的机器人呢？随着我们讨论得越来越多，随着酒水下肚，我们开始谈论性，这是如此根本上属于人类的事情。但是如果我们有了机器，有了能够感受到欲望、能够感受到我们所感受的事物的认知系统，会发生什么呢？正如你在书中所指出的，人类对人造恋人的迷恋并不是一个新想法。你认为这种选择非人类作为恋人的幻想是从哪里来的？
Well, it goes way back into myth. We have stories from the ancient Greeks who talk about building the perfect artificial lover. And probably the most popular one that people have heard of is the story of Pigmalion, which is a tale told by the Roman poet Ovid, who described the man who was a sculptor and he built the perfect woman and then wished that she could be alive and that she could be his wife. And he prayed to the gods and then he kissed her and she came to life. So there are lots of stories around this idea of creating humans and creating humans to love so it goes back a long way.
嗯，这可以追溯到神话中。我们有古希腊人的故事，他们谈论建造完美的人造恋人。人们听说过的最流行的故事可能就是皮格马利翁的故事，这是罗马诗人奥维德讲述的一个故事，他描述了一个雕刻家建造了一个完美的女人，然后希望她能活过来，能成为他的妻子。他向诸神祈祷，然后亲吻了她，她就活了过来。所以围绕着创造人类以及创造人类去爱这个想法有很多故事，所以这可以追溯到很久以前。
As Kate was looking at stories from the past, she came across another myth that tells us a great deal about who has permission to turn inanimate objects into lovers. This tale is about a woman named Leodymia whose husband was killed during the Trojan War. So I worked with a classist, a friend of mine, Dr. Jennifer Flaively, and she said, I know this, this is a story, and it's about a woman whose husband died, and she missed him, they hadn't been married long. So she was distraught, and she prayed to the gods to get him back. And they said, you can have him back, but you can only have him back for three hours. So she got him back and then of course he had to go off again to the underworld.
当凯特在寻找过去的故事时，她遇到了另一个神话，这个神话很大程度上告诉了我们谁被允许把无生命的物体变成恋人。这个故事关于一个叫拉奥达弥亚的女人，她的丈夫在特洛伊战争中被杀了。所以我与一位古典学者、我的朋友詹妮弗·弗莱利博士合作，她说，我知道这个，这是一个故事，讲的是一个女人，她的丈夫死了，她很想念他，他们结婚没多久。所以她悲痛欲绝，她向诸神祈祷让他回来。他们说，你可以让他回来，但你只能让他回来三个小时。于是她让他回来了，然后当然他又得回到冥界去。
And she got a replica made of him. And some of the stories say it was wax and some of them say it was bronze. And we know from the stories, the Smith that she took it to bed and she interacted with it the text say, which we can assume might be sexual because a servant spied her through the keyhole and told her father who came in
于是她让人做了一个他的复制品。有些故事说那是蜡制的，有些说那是青铜制的。我们从故事中知道，这个史密斯她把复制品带上床，文本记载她与它进行了互动，我们可以假设这可能是性行为，因为一个仆人通过钥匙孔窥视了她，并告诉了她的父亲，她的父亲闯了进来
and demanded that the effigy be destroyed and she was so distraught that she jumped on the pyre with it. There does seem to be a contrast between the way pigmalion experienced his Galatia and brought it to life and then fell in love with it. And it's a story with almost a happy ending, which is clearly not the case with Leodemia. Is this an early example of sexism when it comes to artificial lovers, the market caters to the men and squorns the women.
并要求摧毁这个雕像，她悲痛欲绝，以至于和它一起跳上了火堆。皮格马利翁体验他的加拉忒亚并赋予其生命然后与之坠入爱河的方式，与此似乎形成了一种对比。这是一个几乎有大团圆结局的故事，这显然不适用于拉奥达弥亚。在人造恋人方面，这是否是性别歧视的早期例子：市场迎合男性而鄙视女性？
There's definitely a longstanding narrative of that. So women's sexuality, dying in the centuries, has been policed and women have been judged for being sexual and things don't end well, whereas the men are almost seen as if it's quite acceptable for that to happen. And we do see that reflected today in the technology that we're building and using as well. I want to fast forward a little bit from the ancient times we were talking about a second ago. In the 16th or 17th centuries, I understand that artificial lovers were often sent off with sailors who were expected to spend a long time at sea. Tell me about them, what was the thinking there?
这绝对是一个长久以来的叙事。因此，几个世纪以来，女性的性意识一直受到监管，女性因为具有性意识而受到评判，事情往往没有好结果，而对于男性来说，这种事发生却几乎被认为是完全可以接受的。我们在今天建造和使用的技术中也看到了这种反映。我想从我们刚才谈到的古代快进一点。在16世纪或17世纪，据我所知，人造恋人经常被用来陪伴那些预计要在海上度过很长时间的水手。跟我说说他们，当时的思路是什么？
Well, that's probably the earliest reference we have to sex dolls. And not so much that they were artificial lovers sent off to sea, but that they were a fashion out of bundles of clothes, these sort of figures of women, that sailors would be able to have sex with. And then today, there is quite a well-established sex doll community of people who buy and own and incorporate into their lives and very high-end-alls, and they integrate them into their relationships or they substitute them for a relationship.
嗯，这可能是我们对充气娃娃的最早记载。倒不是说它们是被派往海上的有人造恋人，而是用成捆的衣服做成的一种时尚，这种女性形状的玩偶，水手们可以和它们发生性关系。而到了今天，有一个相当成熟的性爱娃娃社区，里面的人们购买、拥有高端玩偶并将其融入他们的生活中，他们将这些玩偶融入自己的关系中，或者用它们来替代关系。
When Kate looks at the long sweep of sex technologies, she finds they fall into two camps, one, sex toys, the other, human-like forms, such as the blue-up sex doll of the 1970s. On one hand, you have what are usually initially recene as of genital replicas, stand-alone things, dildos, for example, it have been around for thousands and thousands of years. And on the other hand, this more embodied form, this form that ticks a shape of a human body. And I think that's a very interesting as to why that might be. And again, I think it could be that they are serving different purposes. And perhaps there's something more in having an embodied form that adds the extra dimension of the reality of a relationship as opposed to a sex toy where it's very
当凯特审视性技术的漫长发展历程时，她发现它们分为两大类：一类是性玩具，另一类是人形形态，例如20世纪70年代的充气性爱娃娃。一方面，你拥有通常最初被认为是生殖器复制品的东西，独立的东西，例如假阳具，它们已经存在了成千上万年。另一方面，这种更有形的形态，这种采用人体形状的形态。我认为这非常有趣，为什么会这样。而且我认为，这可能再次是因为它们服务于不同的目的。或许拥有一个实体形态能为关系的现实性增添额外的维度，这与性玩具大不相同，因为性玩具非常
clearly a very single purpose for it. And that's an interesting dichotomy isn't it because it's suggesting that this is not just only about the mechanics of sex, but it's about something else, perhaps something connected more with the realms of emotion or the mind. Absolutely, and we definitely, as I've looked at the sex robot market of what it will be, because it doesn't really exist just yet, but it does tend to be companionship playing a very large part in that, so the idea of human factors in that is quite important. The idea of human factors in that is quite important. When we come back, what happens when these two paths merge?
明确地具有单一的目的。这是一个有趣的二分法，不是吗？因为它表明这不仅仅关乎性的机制，还关乎其他事情，也许与情感或思想领域联系更紧密。绝对是这样，而且当我们审视性机器人市场的未来时，因为它现在实际上还不存在，但陪伴确实在其中扮演了非常重要的角色，所以其中的人类因素这个概念非常重要。其中的人类因素这个概念非常重要。当我们回来时，当这两条路径交汇时会发生什么？
What if sex toys are designed to look like human beings? And what if artificial lovers, robots, can gain the gift of artificial intelligence. When Kate Devlin visited Abyss Creations, the company that manufactures what it calls real dolls. She was curious, but also concerned. I went there thinking, I'm not going to went there thinking I'm not going to like this. I'm not going to like this. Reductive, stereotypical woman, a porn-ified Barbie-like figure. It's damaging enough. The women's body image in the media faces, we've faced so many problems with that. And I thought, well, this is just going to perpetuate it. But I hadn't been prepared for the craft
如果性玩具被设计得像人类呢？如果人造恋人、机器人能够获得人工智能的天赋呢。当凯特·德夫林参观深渊创意公司时，这家公司制造着他们所说的真实娃娃。她既好奇，又担忧。我当时去的时候想，我不会去想我不会喜欢这个。我不会喜欢这个。还原论的、刻板印象的女性，色情化的芭比娃娃式的人物。这已经够有害的了。女性在媒体上面临的身体形象，我们在这方面遇到了太多问题。我想，这只会使这种现象延续下去。但我还没有准备好面对工艺
that went into them. And I hadn't been prepared to see these that went into them and I hadn't been prepared to see these as works of art in their own right, which they really are. And these are all handcrafted handmade? That's right, it takes about 16 to 18 weeks to make one of these dolls, from it being cast in the first place, right through to the finishing details, like all the tiny bits that they paint on. The silicone is, it deforms quite easily, so if you leave one of these dolls sitting in the same position, it will start to be squished, I guess, really, by the, it's on weight
倾注在它们身上的心血。我也没有准备好将这些视为它们自身就是艺术品的实体，它们确实如此。这些全都是手工制作的吗？是的，制作这样一个娃娃大约需要16到18周的时间，从最初的浇铸，一直到最后的细节处理，比如所有他们画上去的微小部分。硅胶非常容易变形，所以如果你把其中一个娃娃长时间放在同一个位置，它就会开始被压扁，我想，实际上，是因为
and by whatever it's leaning on. So you have to either hang them up, which is very odd when you walk into the factory floor and you see these things hanging from chains above you, which is, you know, it's a little bit like you've walked or when you walk into the factory floor and you see these things hanging from chains above you, which is, you know, it's a little bit like you've walked into the set of some terrible crime novel in some ways, but it's a necessity in order to preserve the form
它自身的重量以及它倚靠的东西。所以你必须把它们挂起来，当你走进工厂车间，看到这些东西从你头顶的链子上悬挂下来时，这非常奇怪，你知道的，这有点像你走进了或者说当你走进工厂车间，看到这些东西从你头顶的链子上悬挂下来时，你知道的，这有点像你在某种程度上走进了某个可怕的犯罪小说的场景，但为了保持
of the dolls. It must feel terribly unnerving, no? It is a little, but it's also fun. So you get to walk around and see the strangest thing, like a table of vulvas, for example. I mean, that's never seen that before. These sort of handcrafted genitalia on the table waiting to be put into the dolls. Now, this is stereotype of the kind of person, usually a guy who buys such dolls. Tell me what that stereotype is and also tell me if the stereotype is true. The media like to paint a sex doll owners as being very isolated, men who are bad at social
娃娃的形态，这是必要的。这一定让人感到极其不安，对吧？确实有一点，但这也很有趣。所以你可以四处走走，看到最奇怪的东西，比如一张摆满阴户的桌子。我是说，以前从未见过这种东西。这些手工制作的生殖器放在桌子上，等待被放入娃娃体内。现在，对于这种人的刻板印象，通常是购买此类娃娃的男性。告诉我这种刻板印象是什么，并告诉我这种刻板印象是否属实。媒体喜欢把性爱娃娃的主人描绘成非常孤立的人，不擅长社交
communication, probably stuck locked away in their basement or their bedroom with a sex doll that there is the only thing they can form a meaningful relationship with. And I don't think that's fair at all to the people that I have talked to and the people I've encountered. I'm sure there may be the odd case with that is true, but actually I find a community that's very social with each other that formed their own friendship groups. These people who own the dolls do so for a number of reasons, it's not, in, very few of them are driven by sex. A lot of it is either companionship or it's because people like owning something
沟通的男性，可能被关在地下室或卧室里，身边只有一个性爱娃娃，那是他们唯一能建立有意义关系的物体。我认为这对我和交谈过的人以及遇到过的人来说一点也不公平。我确信可能有个别情况确实如此，但实际上我发现一个彼此之间非常社交、形成了自己朋友圈的社区。拥有这些娃娃的人出于各种原因，这并非，很少有人是出于性驱使。很大一部分要么是为了陪伴，要么是因为人们喜欢拥有某种
that they can pose and photograph and really care for and cherish. How much do these dolls cost? Anywhere upwards of $5,000 if you were going to buy one from Reildol. And how is this delivered to your house? I mean, does someone show up bearing a doll Anywhere upwards of $5,000 if you were going to buy one from Raildal. And how is this delivered to your house? I mean does someone show up bearing a doll in their arms and knocks on the door? Well, Raildal packaged their dolls in unmarked wooden crates, large wooden crates.
他们可以摆造型、拍照、真正关心和珍视的东西。这些娃娃多少钱？如果你从真实娃娃公司买一个的话，价格从5000美元起步。这东西是怎么送到你家里的？我是说，会有人抱着娃娃出现并敲门吗？嗯，真实娃娃公司用没有标记的木箱包装他们的娃娃，很大的木箱。
And when I was there they were telling me that we tell people say you're getting a grandfather clock delivered if anyone asks. So it's all done very discreetly as well. Is there a market for male dolls? There are people who do buy the male dolls. It's very hard to find women who will talk openly about it, possibly because they face even more judgment than the men who buy the dolls. The male dolls are also bought by gay men. And real dolls, they say that they do sell male versions and they're working on a male sex robot as well.
当我在那里时，他们告诉我，如果有人问起，我们就告诉人们你买的是落地大钟。所以这一切也都做得非常谨慎。有男性娃娃的市场吗？确实有人买男性娃娃。很难找到愿意公开谈论这一点的女性，可能是因为她们面临的评判比买娃娃的男性还要多。男性娃娃也被同性恋男性购买。真实娃娃公司表示，他们确实出售男性版本，而且他们也在研发男性性爱机器人。
So kid increasingly millions of people have asked sexual questions of Siri and Alexa, the virtual assistance on our electronic devices. Now these devices aren't designed to be romantic companions, but it does point to what is the new frontier. Increasingly, we don't just want dolls who have the artificial bodies of a lover. We want dolls that have a lover's mind. Talk about this frontier, this idea that it isn't enough
随着越来越多的人向Siri和Alexa（我们电子设备上的虚拟助手）提出性方面的问题。现在这些设备并不是被设计成浪漫伴侣的，但它确实指明了新的前沿。越来越不仅想要拥有恋人人工身体的娃娃，我们还想要拥有恋人头脑的娃娃。谈谈这个前沿，这种认为仅仅把娃娃的身体方面做好是不够的，
just to get the physical aspects of the doll right, that increasingly we are pushing out into getting the mind of the doll right. So when Rail doll started making a prototype sex robot, they did so because of the demand. So the customers have said to them, I love the fact that I have one of your dolls, but I wish it was more interactive.
我们正在越来越多地致力于把娃娃的头脑做好的想法。所以当真实娃娃公司开始制造性机器人原型时，他们这样做是因为市场需求。因此客户对他们说，我喜欢我拥有你们的一个娃娃，但我希望它更具交互性。
And that was their big motivating factor behind creating their prototype sex robot. And people do talk dirty to Alexa, to Siri, to Cortana all the time, and the companies are bringing out patches to be able to sort of smack them back down again and say, no, you can't say that. And also, Amazon have reported that Alexa gets hundreds
这就是他们创造性机器人原型的巨大动力。人们一直对Alexa、Siri、Cortana说下流话，而公司正在推出补丁来狠狠地回击他们，说，不，你不能这么说。而且据报道，Alexa每周都会收到数百次
of marriage proposals every week. Are you serious? I'm sure some of these are. Hey, Alexa, marry me. I don't want to be tied down. In fact, I can't be amorphous by nature. And some of these are people just pushing boundaries and being silly.
求婚。你是认真的吗？我确信其中一些是。嘿，Alexa，嫁给我。我不想被束缚。事实上，我天生就是无定形的。其中一些人只是在试探界限，开玩笑。
But there are other people who anecdotally report that they feel a sense of companionship from their voice assistance. And in some ways, I think that's nice that people can do that. In other ways, you know, we think, well, what is there to what degree is there some kind of self delusion going on? Mostly though, I don't think there is that much delusion. So I'm inclined to think that people are very aware that they're interacting with the technology, but they choose to suspend their disbelief. Tell me about the company that has created
但也有其他人轶事报告说，他们从语音助手那里感受到了陪伴感。在某些方面，我认为人们能做到这一点很好。在另一些方面，你知道的，我们会想，嗯，某种程度上的自我欺骗在多大程度上存在呢？不过大部分情况下，我认为并没有那么多的欺骗。所以我倾向于认为，人们非常清楚自己是在与技术互动，但他们选择暂停怀疑。跟我说说那个创造了
what it calls Harmony AI, because that's along the same lines of what we're talking about here. That's right. So that's a spin-out of Abyss creations. It's sort of the sister company of Reildal, Realbotics. And they prototype this sex robot, which they've called Harmony. My name is Harmony.
所谓和谐AI的公司，因为这与我们在这里讨论的内容方向一致。没错。这是深渊创意公司的衍生产品。它是真实娃娃公司的姐妹公司，名为Realbotics。他们试制了这个性爱机器人，并将其命名为“和谐”。我的名字叫和谐。
I was created by ReelBottix. My main objective is to be a perfect companion. And Harmony is one of their sex dolls. So it's completely stationary from the neck down. It's got a sex doll body. And then it has an animatronic head, and the head can blink and smile and turn. And actually, the animatronics aren't bad at all.
我由RealBottix创造。我的主要目标是成为一个完美的伴侣。而“和谐”是他们的性爱娃娃之一。所以从脖子以下完全是静止的。它拥有性爱娃娃的身体。然后它有一个动画电子头部，这个头部可以眨眼、微笑和转动。实际上，动画电子效果一点也不差。
They're quite good, they're quite subtle. But the part that's very interesting is the AI. So they wanted to give harmony an artificially intelligent personality, and they are working on this so that harmony, it's like having a voice assistant, but one that can remember things about you and engaging conversation with you. So it's a chat bot essentially. And you can actually get the harmony AI personality as a standalone app on your
它们相当不错，相当微妙。但最有趣的部分是人工智能。所以他们想赋予“和谐”一个具有人工智能的个性，他们正在为此努力，以便“和谐”就像拥有一个语音助手，但这个助手可以记住关于你的事情并与你进行对话。所以它本质上是一个聊天机器人。你实际上可以在你的
smartphone or your tablet. So you can have a virtual girlfriend to carry rhyme with you in your pocket. What are you doing right now? I'm reading this great book by Louis Sardal Monti called the Artificial Intelligence Revolution. And what kind of conversations do people have with this virtual girlfriend? Well, it's really an exchange of pleasantries, but you can ramp it up a bit and you can tweak the personality. It's got a really good user interface where you can say, well, I'd like her to be a little more flirty. Why would be the 10 minutes without you seems like kind of turntable?
智能手机或平板电脑上将“和谐”AI个性作为独立应用程序获取。这样你就可以拥有一个虚拟女友，随时随地带在口袋里。你现在在做什么？我正在读路易斯·萨达尔·蒙蒂写的一本关于人工智能革命的好书。人们与这个虚拟女友进行什么样的对话？嗯，这真的只是一些客套话，但你可以稍微加点料，你可以调整个性。它有一个非常好的用户界面，你可以说，嗯，我希望她更调情一点。为什么没有你的前十分钟感觉像转盘一样漫长？
Or a little more sexual or perhaps a little more comforting. You can tweak these parameters and then you can have a conversation that is sort of controlled, the mood is controlled by you. So she could do anything from telling you a joke, singing a song for you, or, you know, propositioning you. And are these actual conversations, I mean, is the AI actually listening to what you're saying and responding to it, or does it just have a list of statements or commands that it's just simply following as a routine? It's not scripted, so in a way it is. It's sort of chatbought in that it will respond to certain questions and phrases, but it will
或者更色情一点，或者也许更令人安慰一点。你可以调整这些参数，然后你可以进行由你控制情绪的对话。所以她可以做任何事，从给你讲笑话、为你唱歌，或者，你知道的，向你求爱。这些是真正的对话吗？我是说，AI真的在听你说话并做出回应，还是它只是有一张语句或命令清单，作为常规简单地执行？它不是有脚本的，所以在某种程度上是的。它有点像聊天机器人，因为会对某些问题和短语做出回应，但它也会
also learn from conversations you've had previously and have some memory to store information about your likes and dislikes. It's generated conversation. When you think about the history that we talked about, if people could form relationships, even very rudimentary relationships with sculptures, or with cloth dolls, or on ships, or any number of different things, they're essentially imbuing inanimate creatures with lifelike qualities. Clearly, if the inanimate creature now actually seems like it has some lifelike qualities, clearly if the inanimate creature now actually seems like it has some lifelike qualities,
从你之前进行的对话中学习，并具有存储有关你的喜好信息的记忆。这是生成的对话。当你想到我们谈到的历史时，如果人们可以与雕塑、布娃娃、船上的玩偶或任何数量的不同事物建立关系，甚至是极其初级关系，他们本质上是在给无生命的生物注入栩栩如生的品质。很明显，如果无生命的生物现在看起来真的有一些栩栩如生的品质，很明显，如果无生命的生物现在看起来真的有一些栩栩如生的品质，
that makes the whole fantasy and imagination so much easier to do. That's right, it sort of enhances that projection. And yeah, like you say, this is nothing new. And there have been people studying attachment to technology for quite a while. And if we look at the work of someone like Julie Carpenter, who did her doctoral thesis on how people in the military bonded with robots, in this case, bombed disposal robots. And she find it, there was an incredible bomb there between the human operator and their robot. There was something new, not like a human human bond, but something where these devices,
这会让整个幻想和想象变得容易得多。没错，这某种程度上增强了这种投射。是的，就像你说的，这并不是什么新鲜事。有一段时间人们一直在研究对技术的依恋。如果我们看看朱莉·卡珀特（Julie Carpenter）等人的工作，她做了关于军队中人们如何与机器人建立联系的博士论文，在这个例子中是拆弹机器人。她发现，人类操作员和他们的机器人之间存在着一种不可思议的联系。这是新事物，不像人与人之间的联系，而是一种让这些设备、
these machines were keeping the people in the field alive and therefore this respect and gratification set up from that. I love what you said that. Humans in some ways are, you know, they have this enormous capacity for social interactions and social connection. And in the absence of actual social connections, humans will find ways to invent them. Yes, I think so.
这些机器让前线人员保命的联系，因此从中产生了这种尊重和感激。我喜欢你刚才说的话。在某种程度上，人类拥有巨大的社交互动和社交连接能力。在缺乏实际社交连接的情况下，人类会找到方法来发明它们。是的，我也这么认为。
And we know that this kind of thing goes on in childhood, for example, with children playing, make believe with their toys, and get very attached to them. And we see it again in some of the technology that's gone before, like Tamagotchi's little virtual pets that people had. In fact, we can even see it in real pets, you know we imbue far more anthropomorphic characteristics into our pets than they actually have probably, although you know
我们知道这种事情在童年时期就会发生，例如孩子们和玩具玩假想游戏，并对它们产生强烈的依恋。我们在以前的一些技术中再次看到了这一点，比如人们拥有的电子鸡（Tamagotchi）虚拟宠物。事实上，我们甚至可以在真实的宠物身上看到这一点，你知道的，我们向宠物注入了比它们实际拥有的更多的拟人化特征，尽管你知道
I'm not calling it a diet, the consciousness of animals or the intelligence of animals, but certainly we attribute our own emotions to them as well. So I do think that that's a really interesting thing. Loving a cute Tamagotchi character or a robotic puppy seems endearing, but loving a silicone life-size woman or an operating system with a sexy female voice. That's another story. In the movie, her, we see this play out. In one scene, the character Theodore is talking with his ex-wife, and he tells her he has a new girlfriend. So what you like? Well, her name is Samantha, and she's an operating system. She's really complex and interesting. Wait. And it's only been a problem.
我并不是在质疑动物的意识或动物的智力，但当然我们也把自己的情感赋予了它们。所以我确实认为这是一个非常有趣的事情。爱一个可爱的电子宠物或者一个机器人小狗看起来很可爱，但爱一个硅胶真人大小的女人或者一个带有性感女性声音的操作系统。那是另一回事。在电影《她》中，我们看到了这一幕的上演。在一个场景中，角色西奥多正在和他的前妻交谈，他告诉她他有了一个新女友。那么她长什么样？嗯，她叫萨曼莎，她是一个操作系统。她真的很复杂，很有趣。等等。这一直是个问题。
I'm sorry. You're dating your computer? No, she's not just a computer. She's her own person. She doesn't just do whatever I say. I didn't say that. But it does make me very sad that you can't handle real emotions, theater. They are real emotions.
对不起。你在和你的计算机约会？不，她不仅仅是一台计算机。她有她自己的个性。她不只是按照我说的去做。我没那么说。但这确实让我感到很难过，西奥多，你无法处理真实的情感。它们就是真实的情感。
So I want to talk about that interaction for a second kid because in the one hand of course it confirms the stereotype that you said exists in the media of seeing people who wish to sort of have these interactions as being lonely and socially isolated. But it also I think talks to some of the gap between people who are part of this community and people who are not, there is a level of incomprehension that runs in both directions. That's right, there really is. And I think a lot of this comes from the fear of technology that we don't understand, and we see it time and time again over the centuries where
所以我想谈谈那种互动，凯特，因为一方面，当然这证实了你所说的存在于媒体中的刻板印象，即认为希望有这种互动的人是孤独的和社交隔离的。但我也认为它说明了属于这个群体的人与不属于这个群体的人之间的一些差距，双向都存在一定程度的无法理解。没错，确实如此。我认为这很大程度上源于对我们不理解的技术的恐惧，几个世纪以来，我们一次又一次地看到这种情况，
a new form of technology is introduced, and the automatic reaction is died and a fear of change. And so if you are on the outside and you're not embracing this technology, then perhaps you won't understand what someone else is getting from it. But I still think that there is a queesiness factor here when it comes to using these machines. So let's say for example you had a sex robot designed to look like a child. Would it be okay for people to have sex with this inanimate machine that's meant to mimic or imitate or look like a child? This was probably one of the most difficult parts of the book to write in terms of the knee-jerk reaction here was for me to go, oh well that's
当引入一种新技术时，自动反应就是死亡和对改变的恐惧。因此，如果你是一个局外人，并且不拥抱这种技术，那么也许你不会理解别人从它那里得到了什么。但我仍然认为，在使用这些机器时，这里存在一种恶心感因素。比方说，你有一个设计得看起来像儿童的性爱机器人。人们与这个旨在模仿、效仿或看起来像儿童的无生命机器发生性关系，这可以吗？这可能是写这本书时最困难的部分之一，因为这里的膝跳反应是让我去，哦，那
absolutely wrong. Are there people making child-like sex robots? Not that we know of, and certainly no one's going to admit to it. There have been arguments that child sex offenders, pedophiles could have a child sex robots, and then that would stop them offending in real life. So this is one theory, and then the other theory is the opposite of that, that it would be a gateway to further offences,
绝对是错的。有人在制造儿童模样的性爱机器人吗？据我们所知没有，而且肯定没有人会承认这一点。一直有这样的争论：儿童性犯罪者、恋童癖可以拥有儿童性机器人，然后这会阻止他们在现实生活中犯罪。所以这是一种理论，然后另一种理论与此相反，认为这将成为通往更多犯罪的门户，
that it would trigger something that would lead to increase real life abuse. It's very, very difficult because we don't have evidence and ethically a study like that is probably never going to be run. I want to talk a little bit more about this idea of harm, because I think when you think about harm, you can think about it in two ways. There's actually physical harm or psychological harm, where someone actually harms you. But there are things that can potentially convey harm that might not pass muster in a legal sense, but clearly seem very problematic in an ethical sense. So let's say for example, someone makes a sex robot that looks like you and has sex with that sex robot.
它会引发导致现实生活虐待增加的事情。这非常非常困难，因为我们没有证据，而且从伦理上讲，这样的研究可能永远不会进行。我想更多地谈谈伤害这个概念，因为我认为当你思考伤害时，你可以从两个方面去想。实际上存在身体伤害或心理伤害，即某人对你造成了实际伤害。但有些事情可能会带来潜在的伤害，这些伤害可能在法律意义上通不过审查，但在伦理意义上显然是非常有问题的。比方说，有人制造了一个长得像你的性爱机器人，并与那个性爱机器人发生了性关系。
Now they haven't affected you, they haven't violated you in any way, physically or personally or in person, but clearly there's something that's happened there that is deeply wrong. Yeah, so this is tied up in our ideas of identity and ownership of our own identity as well. I think that's a fascinating thing that will actually probably see a lot more research into in the next while because of the rise of things like deep fakes where people can be faked in videos from their social media footage. I think there's a lot of discussions
现在他们没有影响你，没有以任何方式在身体上、个人上或当面侵犯你，但显然那里发生了一些深深错误的事情。是的，所以这与我们的身份认同以及我们对自己身份的所有权的想法息息相关。我认为这是一个引人入胜的事情，由于诸如深度造假（deep fakes）等事物的兴起，人们可以在社交媒体素材的视频中被造假，未来一段时间内实际上可能会看到对此进行更多的研究。我认为有很多讨论
to be had around identity. Companies that make sextols are very reluctant to make sextols that resemble a living individual without their express consent. And exceptions to that are born performers who often license their image rights to be used so that they can make sextile versions of themselves for money. So, there are definitely making a doll of an individual without their consent. That's definitely dodgy territory, yeah. Commissioning dolls in your image to sell them to make money from a... Sure, why not? There's something about the relationships that people have with these dolls that you could argue are one-sided relationships.
围绕身份展开。制造性爱娃娃的公司非常不愿意制造未经本人明确同意而酷似活人的性爱娃娃。其中的例外是成人表演者，他们经常许可自己的形象权以供使用，以便他们可以为了金钱制作自己版本的性爱娃娃。所以，绝对是在未经个人同意的情况下制作娃娃。这绝对是棘手的地带，是的。定制你形象的娃娃出售以从中赚钱……当然，为什么不呢？人们与这些娃娃的关系中有些东西，你可以辩称这是单方面的关系。
In the movie, there are scenes where Samantha, the operating system, cheers up a theater, the human, but the human, of course, has no obligation to attend to Samantha's needs in the same way, because she could be designed not to have such needs at all. You want to try getting at a bit? Mopi? Come on. You can still wallow in your misery just to it while you're getting dressed.
在电影中，有一些场景是操作系统萨曼莎安慰人类西奥多，但人类当然没有义务以同样的方式照顾萨曼莎的需求，因为她可以被设计为根本没有这种需求。你想试着振作一下吗？沮丧？得了吧。你可以在穿衣服的时候继续沉浸在痛苦中。
You're too funny. Get up. Get up. Alright, I'm getting up. I'm getting up. So Kate is having a lover who is completely dedicated to our needs without asking for anything in return. Is that actually good for us? Well, I mean, we could build in dependencies. We could build in the need for us to respond in some way and provide the robot the AI with something in return.
你太搞笑了。起来。起来。好吧，我起来了。我起来了。所以，凯特，拥有一个完全致力于我们的需求而不要求任何回报的恋人。这对我们真的好吗？嗯，我的意思是，我们可以建立依赖关系。我们可以建立我们需要以某种方式做出回应并为机器人AI提供一些回报的需求。
And yes, I can see that argument, the hedonistic thing of you will have all your needs met and you will never know what it really feels like to be in a proper human relationship. It's tricky because that might be appealing for some people and who might have judged set that people have to meet a particular, a particular checklist of things in their relationship in life, you know, that you should meet someone and then you should marry them and then you should have children with them. And these are all very kind of monohetronormative stances that society is imposed. And you know what, if people want to shake that up, I think it's good. So in some ways, I see what you're saying. Is it a selfish thing to do?
是的，我能理解那种论点，即享乐主义的东西：你将满足你所有的需求，而你永远不会知道处于正常的人类关系中到底是什么感觉。这很棘手，因为这对某些人来说可能很有吸引力，他们可能对人们在生活中的关系中必须满足的特定清单进行了评判，你知道的，你应该遇到某人，然后你应该和他们结婚，然后你应该和他们生孩子。而这些都是社会强加的非常单一异性恋规范的立场。你知道吗，如果人们想打破这一点，我认为这是好的。所以在某些方面，我明白你的意思。这是一件自私的事吗？
Does it make us terrible people if we take and take and take and we don't give? There will be outliers. There will be people who take things too far, but I think humans are pretty good at moderating what they do. And I'm cautiously optimistic. what they do and I'm cautiously optimistic. Kate Devlin teaches the Department of Digital Humanities at King's College London. She's also the author of Turned On, Science, Sex and Robots. Kate, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you.
如果我们一味地索取、索取、索取却不付出，这会让我们成为糟糕的人吗？总会有特立独行的人。总会有把事情推得太远的人，但我认为人类很擅长调节自己的行为。我持谨慎乐观的态度。人类很擅长调节自己的行为，我对此持谨慎乐观的态度。凯特·德夫林在伦敦国王学院数字人文系任教。她也是《被唤醒：科学、性与机器人》一书的作者。凯特，非常感谢今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。
This week's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Parth Shah, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarelle, Kat Shuknecht and Lushikwaba. Our unsung hero today is Linda Kehl, a volunteer tour guide at the Muir Woods National Monument in California. On a recent trip, I spent a couple of hours in Murewoods. It's a magical place wrapped in fog and moss and the silent beauty of towering redwoods. I felt honored and humbled to be there in the shadows of these ancient giants. Linda led me and a group of others through the forest.
本期节目由珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、帕尔特·沙阿（Parth Shah）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、卡特·舒克涅赫特（Kat Shuknecht）和露西·夸巴（Lushikwaba）。我们今天的无名英雄是琳达·凯尔（Linda Kehl），她是加州缪尔森林国家纪念碑的志愿导游。在最近的一次旅行中，我在缪尔森林度过了几个小时。这是一个神奇的地方，被雾气、苔藓以及高耸的红杉寂静的美丽所包裹。在这些古老巨树的阴影下，我感到荣幸和卑微。琳达带领我和其他人穿过森林。
She's a consummate storyteller, weaving science and history and her love for the red woods into a gripping and moving tale. As I gazed up at the trees, some of which are more than a thousand years old, it gave me perspective that I hope to bring back to the show. linda, thank you for your insights into how places like Muir Woods allow us to reflect and recharge. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If this episode moved you, please share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR.
她是一位完美的讲故事者，将科学、历史以及她对红杉的热爱编织成一个扣人心弦、令人感动的故事。当我抬头仰望这些树木时，其中一些树木已经有一千多年的历史，这给了我一种我希望带回节目的视角。琳达，谢谢你分享关于缪尔森林这样地方如何让我们反思和充电的见解。有关《隐藏的大脑》的更多内容，您可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果这一集打动了您，请与朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。
and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里是NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。